nous sommes au cœur de Saint-Denis dans
la rue Jules Aubert une rue où les
casses traditionnelles disparaissent à
mesure qu'on va vers la mer pour laisser
place à un fouillis de boutiques et
autres pas de porte
Gilbert Jules Aubert ça vous dit quelque
chose
est-ce que vous savez qui était Jules
Aubert
je sais pas peut-être à la mer je pense
que c'était un ancien maire
de Saint-Denis
Joseph pierre Jules Aubert est né à
Saint-Paul le 29 avril 1867
après ces études de médecine à Paris il
rentre à la Réunion et ouvre un modeste
cabinet à Saint-Denis où il dispense des
consultations gratuites son mariage avec
Camille battu de Rosemont met un terme à
cet engagement altruiste désormais c'est
l'aristocratie que soigne le docteur
Robert et ses riches malades qui le
poussent à s'engager en politique mais
chasser le naturel il revient en galop
c'est la gauche prolétaire que va
choisir le bon docteur en 1904 ce
radical socialiste était lu maire de
Saint-Denis l'année suivante il était du
député contre son opposant de droite
Gasparin il siège dès lors à Paris aux
côtés du ministre de la guerre le
socialiste Milan
1906 voit son retour dans l'île et le
renouvellement du mandat en lice deux
candidats Gasparin et Aubert pour une
campagne électorale d'une rare violence
lors d'un meeting Jules Aubert reçoit un
galet en pleine tête choqué il se
désiste et puis surprise après son
élection sans opposition Lucien Gasparin
retourne sa veste et rejoint le groupe
radical socialiste d'Auber dégoûté le
docteur reprend son cabinet et fonde La
Dépêche un journal qui défend sa
politique plus tard il retrouve un siège
de conseillers général de Saint-Benoît
le patriotisme dont Jules et son épouse
font preuve pendant la guerre de 14-18
le replace sur le siège de maire de
Saint-Denis puis sur celui de sénateur
il meurt à Paris en 1928